The old politicians in the West, yes,
every accusation is a confession. You
guys are the real pedophiles. Took these
white girls, raped them, recorded it,
and used it as a blackmail to tell you
to go to flipping Iran. So, we, the
British people and the Westerns around
the world, are paying £1.86.
Everything you own, from your clothes to
your car, to your wife or your husband,
is going to forget you and move on and
be replaced the moment you die. That's
what Allah says,
"You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves." Brothers
and sisters, Masjid Norway, the one that
we built, is looking to another masjid
around the area of Norway, subhanallah,
where there's so many Muslims that do
not have somewhere to pray. This masjid
is only $500,000, and any donation that
you give will go towards your akhirah
because when you enter that grave,
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, make it
count, brothers and sisters, and donate
towards this masjid, inshallah, a new
project that's only $500,000, and
believe me, if every single one of us
give £1, £10, £100, £1,000, that's going
to be something you will never regret on
Yawm al-Qiyamah, and everything that you
lose is going to perish and go, but your
deeds on Yawm al-Qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link, inshallah. Let's get
to the video.
As a British Muslim, I'm angry. Why am I
angry, brothers and sisters? Not just
because of the petrol prices and the
diesel prices, whatever diesel. It gets
worse. £1.53.9.
Diesel is now £1.86.9. Before I went to
Mecca and came back, that was 40p
cheaper. Now, we're paying extra 40p.
Now, am I here to do videos about the
petrol prices? No. I want to talk about
what this is a cause of. Now, you might
be looking and saying, "Well, brother
Ali, we know what the cause is. It's the
Iran war." Well, duh, yeah, but where
does it all go back to, which is very,
very important for us to talk about? Cuz
I'm driving past this petrol and I'm
thinking, [clears throat] "Yo, why is
everyone around the world paying the
price
of a war started because of what? Let me
tell you what, it all goes back to
Israel. Yeah, that's right, the
Zionists. And I'm not trying to
implicate every Jew here cuz I've got a
lot of Jewish friends in Stampford Hill,
Rabbi Beck that I speak to. Don't
conflate them with these absolute maniac
Zionists not not heads.
It all goes back to an island, Epstein's
island that we all know.
Uh goes to Robert Maxwell, his daughter
Ghislaine Maxwell, who worked with the
Mossad, it's an open secret, and they
lured these handful of people into
islands, raped young white girls. Yes,
when it's the grooming gangs that do it,
we condemn it in the Sharia, we would
hang them upside down. We know how to
deal with these criminals. We don't give
them a hot bath, hot shower, hot food,
nice hot environment with books and
PlayStation to play. No, the Sharia
doesn't deal with the
the cost of the taxpayer. No, it deals
with it once and for all in a maybe in
Trafalgar Square so the other criminals
can see what happens to them. But when
it's an Asian person doing anything like
that, all the hell breaks loose. Tommy
Robinson, the cokehead, his little
right-hand man Liam Tuff, who's not so
tough, who didn't have the guts to meet
me face to face, and Danny Tommo, who
got absolutely annihilated by Smarter
Than You, who humiliated him and did a
fantastic job on him.
It all goes back to this island. And in
this island, they took young white
girls, innocent white girls, flew free
from France, yes, in this Lolita
Express, okay? You know where that goes
to, a novel uh pertaining to a uh older
man um taking advantage of a little
girl.
Anyways, so
took them to the islands, secretly
recorded them, raped them,
groomed them, yes, trafficked them, and
they have connections to Les Wexner, who
owns Victoria's Secret, where the models
were probably channeled through there.
Anyways, and innocent girls, and I
watched a documentary on Netflix. And
then they recorded your politicians,
your politicians in the West, yes, every
accusation is a conviction. You guys are
the real pedophiles, okay? And you think
we are? Never. So, and they recorded it,
took these white girls, raped them,
recorded it, and used it as a blackmail
to tell you to go to flipping Iran. So,
we, the British people and the
Westerners around the world, are paying
£1.86. Now, I don't give a damn.
I don't care about this petrol. This
issue is not that. The issue is what is
done to those innocent people. And then,
guess what? Now, they're sending these
white young men and white women to go
and fight their war. While in Israel,
they spit at you cuz you have the cross.
And they believe your Jesus, your God is
burning in the hellfire, and his mother
is an adulterer. Hmm. And then, there is
And Islam came to honor and dignify
Jesus. So, before we can expect the
price and be upset about the 40 p per
liter, just know how many white girls
were raped, and then how many white
American young men, women, and children
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Young men and women are being sent to
die for Israel.
So, that's why I wanted to show I just
wanted to bring that to your attention.
So, every time I go past a petrol pump,
just know this was something to walk cuz
they care about Iranian girls when they
bombed on purposefully 160
Iranian innocent girls who were
massacred are the biggest problem. And
like I mentioned in the Quran, if you
ask them, they'll say, "What? We are
just peacemakers."
Hellfire is where they belong. And we as
Muslims will bring highlight to this.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, God
Almighty, destroy these pedophiles in
this life and in the hereafter.